este es el vídeo de biología esencial
número 24 y hablaremos de la regulación
de la temporización y coordinación en el
desarrollo es decir cómo es que pasamos
de un cigoto el óvulo fertilizado a un
embrión y después a un bebé y después a
ustedes entonces como pasamos de una
célula con su adn a todas las células
que hay en un bebé y que se encargan de
diferentes funciones aún cuando tienen
exactamente el mismo adn bueno en este
vídeo hablaremos de todos esos nuevos
descubrimientos empezaremos hablando de
las semillas y de cómo germina las
semillas pueden permanecer latentes por
mucho tiempo pero en algún momento
cobran vida por ejemplo como pasamos de
esas células que existen en una semilla
a un árbol bueno de todas esas etapas es
de lo que se trata el desarrollo y la
primera etapa es la diferenciación
celular en el que cada una de las
células tiene que decidir qué
tipo de célula será y expresará una
proteína de tejido específica entonces
en algún momento las células formarán un
embrión y las células que hay adentro de
ese embrión inducirán a otras células a
diferenciarse en su tipo celular en esta
etapa les mostraré cómo ocurre el
trasplante genético cómo se usa en
algunos factores de transcripción y cómo
funciona y también veremos la muerte
celular que es tan importante como el
crecimiento celular por ejemplo
hablaremos de cómo se forman los dedos y
los pies y la importancia de la
regulación de los microarn y finalmente
hablaremos de los genes somió ticos
veremos cómo es que guían a las células
que forman las diferentes partes del
cuerpo para que sepan en dónde deben de
ir y hablaremos un poco de mutación
entonces empecemos con la germinación de
las semillas
por ejemplo si tenemos una semilla de
girasol que sacamos de la botana y la
plantamos tal vez no crezca porque tiene
mucha sal pero si tenemos una semilla
natural de girasol y la plantamos
crecerá y para que eso suceda
necesitamos de dos cosas la primera es
que se necesita aumentar un poco la
temperatura y la otra es agregar agua
entonces si tenemos la temperatura
adecuada y regamos correctamente las
semillas germinarán y con el tiempo
crecerá un bonito girasol pero miren las
células de la raíz serán distintas a las
células de las hojas y a las del tallo
pero como se determina eso claro con las
etapas de desarrollo por las que pasan
todas las células hasta convertirse en
un organismo entonces empecemos con la
diferenciación celular la diferenciación
celular explica cómo las células se
convierten en células específicas por
ejemplo aquí tenemos células madre
humanas
creciendo sobre una matriz formada por
fibroblastos de ratón pero esas células
adentro de nosotros en algún momento se
especializaron y por ejemplo estas son
células nerviosas y una vez que las
células madres se convierten en esa
célula no podrán volver a ser una célula
madre una vez que eligen convertirse en
esa célula no pueden volver atrás esto
se puede hacer en el laboratorio pero en
la vida real no sucede así aunque a
veces hay algunas excepciones pero como
es que las células se transforman en
otras células bueno todas tienen
proteínas de tejido específicas por
ejemplo si esta es una célula madre que
es muy sencilla porque solo tiene un par
de cromosomas que se encuentran adentro
del núcleo como pasamos de esa célula
madre a un glóbulo rojo oa una neurona
oa una célula de la piel cómo se
transforman en eso bueno miren el adn en
cada una de estas células existe
pero como se formará cada una de estas
células si el adn es igual bueno lo que
descubrimos es que aquí hay unos genes
como por ejemplo estos de color rojo
cuando una célula decide que quiere ser
un glóbulo rojo lo que creemos que
sucede es que todas las partes del adn
que no expresan proteínas para crear
glóbulos rojos todo ese adn se inactiva
y solamente se queda activado el adn de
los genes que en este caso sólo pueden
formar glóbulos rojos
entonces aún cuando el adn es el mismo
en un glóbulo rojo y en una neurona los
genes que se expresan son diferentes por
ejemplo para el caso de la neurona
supongamos que se activan estos genes
que estoy poniendo de color azul y todos
los genes que hay para formar glóbulos
rojos se inactiva y solo se expresan los
genes neuronales entonces cuando las
células toman una decisión y escogen qué
tipo de se
o la quieren ser a eso se le conoce como
diferenciación celular y eso ocurre
prácticamente desde el primer día de
gestación
veamos cómo funciona supongamos que un
cigoto un óvulo fecundado se duplica a
sí mismo varias veces por medio de la
mitosis así se crean muchas células
madre y estas células se pueden
convertir en la célula que quieran en
nosotros algunas forman una esfera la
blas tú la que después se pliega dentro
de sí misma para formar la gastro la que
a su vez se pliega hacia el interior y
forma el tracto digestivo y quizá otras
células decidan convertirse en otras
partes como nervios huesos o músculos
pero como es que las células determinan
qué tipo de célula quieren ser bueno
para explicar eso tenemos a los factores
de transcripción esto quiere decir que
las células van a expresar o liberar
proteínas y esas proteínas determinarán
el tipo de célula en el que se
convertirán
se los explicaré supongamos que estos
son los factores de transcripción de
arriba y de abajo entonces por ejemplo
si estas células son el resultado de la
formación de las células madre van a
expresar estos factores de transcripción
en este caso el factor de transcripción
de arriba se comunicará con el adn que
hay adentro de la célula y activará las
proteínas específicas para una célula
que formará la parte de arriba de un
cuerpo y esto generará más factores de
transcripción para las células que se
encuentren adyacentes a eso les mostraré
supongamos que este es el factor de
transcripción producido por esta célula
vamos a identificarla como una célula
amarilla y esa célula crea factores de
transcripción que se mueven hacia las
células adyacentes y ahora esas células
expresarán más factores de transcripción
y así es como determinarán en qué tipo
de células se van a convertir
las células saben que se encuentran
arriba éstas saben que se encuentran
abajo y éstas saben que se encuentran en
medio así es como se generan los
factores de transcripción que ayudan a
que un organismo pase de células madre a
embrión y sabían que todos nosotros
empezamos siendo hembra sí pero existe
un gen específico que se conoce como el
gen srf y es un gen determinante del
sexo en la región ya porque se encuentra
en el cromosoma que y lo que sucede es
que en los machos existe un cromosoma x
y uno ye y este gen se transmitirá a las
células adyacentes así es como ustedes
se convierten en un niño pero si no hay
presencia del gen srf permanecemos y
nacemos siendo niña por ejemplo si
tenemos xy nos convertimos en niño pero
también podríamos tener x x xi y también
seremos niño incluso si tenemos x
xxx y seguiremos siendo un niño nada más
por la presencia de ese gen pero si
tenemos xx y sin la presencia de y somos
niña ahora se hizo un estudio muy
interesante sobre la importancia de la
inducción embrionaria es decir la idea
de que estas células pueden inducir a
las células adyacentes para convertirse
en algo estos son unos peces encontrados
en méjico y los científicos descubrieron
que como algunos de estos peces viven en
cavernas con el tiempo perdieron sus
ojos entonces buscaron un pez similar y
que si tiene ojos así que hicieron un
experimento en el que trasplantaron el
cristalino de los ojos de ese pez al
embrión del pez de caverna y resultó que
los peces ciegos desarrollaron
nuevamente un ojo normal pero cuando
intentaron el caso contrario con un
embrión de este pez no pasó nada así que
existe algo en las células de estos ojos
que desencadenaron algo
la formación de todas las partes de un
ojo como la retina y el nervio óptico
todo eso funcionó correctamente con esta
inducción y bueno a esto se le conoce
como trasplante y esos estudios
demostraron su importancia ahora además
de la diferenciación celular la muerte
celular también es muy importante mire
todas las partes de este embrión humano
se desarrollarán mediante la
diferenciación y la inducción pero
observen que entre los dedos y los dedos
de los pies las células se están
muriendo y a ese proceso se le conoce
como apoptosis así que no solamente el
crecimiento de las células es importante
también la muerte de las células es muy
importante en la formación de un nuevo
organismo y un excelente ejemplo de eso
es la drosophila la mosca de fruta este
es el embrión de una drosophila y este
es el adulto pero la apoptosis o muerte
celular es muy importante en esa
regulación
existen diferentes genes para eso que
los científicos han identificado y me
encantan los nombres por ejemplo están
los genes ocultos severos y segadores y
en una drosophila estos tres genes
provocan que las células mueran
ahora otra cosa muy importante es el
micro a rn un micro arn es una sola
hebra de rn que se encuentra en todos
los organismos y lo que hace es que
interrumpe al rn con lo que se crean
proteínas pero los científicos se
encontraron que si se interrumpe el rn
en la drosophila es decir si nos
deshacemos del micro a rn todos estos
genes se vuelven locos y no se logra
convertir el embrión en mosca entonces
estos genes se pueden descontrolarse si
no tenemos micro arn para regularlos y
que pueda ocurrir el desarrollo y bueno
ya sabemos que el desarrollo consiste en
el crecimiento de las células pero
también en su muerte
micro y rn son muy importantes para
regular todo ese desarrollo y finalmente
me gustaría que hablemos de los genes
somió ticos los genes somió ticos se
encuentran en nosotros en las moscas de
fruta en los ratones pero primero se
estudiaron en las moscas de fruta y se
encontró que hay una serie de genes en
el cromosoma de la mosca que le indican
a sus células en dónde colocar las
partes de su cuerpo ahora estos genes
nos llevan a otros genes y se genera una
gran cascada de genes impulsando la
formación de un ojo o de una antena o de
una pata pero estos genes son muy
importantes para indicar en dónde va
cada cosa eso es lo que hacen los genes
somáticos y los más importantes son los
genes hox y bueno los genes son bióticos
nos llevan a las mutaciones por ejemplo
existe una mutación conocida como ultra
víctor acz este es un gen que provoca la
duplicación del tórax entonces
mosca de fruta normalmente se ve así
porque recuerden que en general la mosca
y los insectos están compuestos por
cabeza tórax y abdomen cuando tiene una
mutación o un cambio en este gen crece
con dos tórax y cuatro alas y si por
ejemplo hay una mutación en el gen
antena pedja lo que sucede es que una de
las patas de la mosca crecerá en la
cabeza suena un poco aterrador parece
ciencia ficción pero esto nos explica
que adentro de las moscas de fruta e
incluso adentro de nosotros hay una
serie de genes que se encargan de decir
en dónde van las diferentes partes de
nuestro cuerpo entonces un embrión se
desarrolla en un feto y con el tiempo
ese efecto se desarrolló en ustedes por
eso los genes somáticos son muy
importantes para guiar la formación de
las células en el sitio correcto de
todas las partes de nuestro cuerpo
espero que les sirva